[Music]
so recently the small business loan
program i scotty completed yeah the sba
it was it was gone and forty nine
billion dollars and funding is now gone
why is it gone oh because chris got cut
the line that's actually exactly what
we're talking about is Ruth's Chris
Steakhouse they got their this group
received a total of twenty million
dollars
oh it's what's-his-name um he's a Texas
billionaire from he's just got this
restaurant
he owns a Bubba Gump shrimp he owns uh
he's got a small businessman okay
business no he's a he's one he's one of
the biggest Giants of restaurant chains
I forgot his name though he was uh was
that Ruth or Chris Chris yeah he owns a
crispity Group Inc the restaurant group
yeah Harvard also took like ten million
yeah Harvard did so Harvard little small
business Harvard hobby
it took nine mill at least they're
giving away free classes right now
online classes if you guys want to have
a Harvard education and the stimulus
gave what was it the Kennedy Center like
twenty million dollars or thirty million
dollars and they to keep their employees
and they immediately fired the entire
Orchestra and they've just been laying
people are you [ __ ] kidding
it's a [ __ ] it's such a scam this is
like the recession when that uh what was
that valence company AIG no what do you
mean no Fannie Mae it's not it's it's
insurance Fannie Mae is an all right
yeah was it okay well I forgot which one
but they went on vacation oh oh yeah AIG
so they they went on and they spent like
all this [ __ ] money that caused
millions of dollars as to celebrate for
the for the bailout but yeah yeah yeah
that's crazy we got a lot of people are
pissed there's a lot of petitions going
around for example of this one petition
has over 200,000
signatures Oh like calling for Ruth's
Chris Steakhouse to return the loans and
claiming that if they don't they will be
ashamed forever whoa I've never been to
one are there's never heard of them
before I've been to one I know what if
they're steaks are good and I want them
to stay alive it was fine is it good
enough to have two first names in the
title nothing everyone owns the other
it's Ruth I don't like people with two
first names either mmm but ten million
though that's a lot 20 20 yeah for the
girl oh man imagine being a restaurant
owner yourself and then this big like
big company gets 20 million you get zip
yep hey guess how they cut the line I
wonder oh no you think it's a
coincidence that they got to cut the
line like who else got to cut the line
like just wait we don't even know how if
they're spreading that 20 million within
all of their restaurants and it's not
just one chain it kind of makes sense so
for example something we can relate to
is the the Taco Bell group they own
pizza they own all these other chains
like Yum Brands Yum Brands yeah yeah so
imagine if they got a huge bailout it's
going through all the taco bells all the
Pizza Hut's all the [ __ ] Long John
Silver's everything that they own across
the whole nation so then they're
spreading that money out that way that
makes sense that makes sense so this
brand it might be the father brand the
pear brand yeah they're claiming that
this would be for primarily for payroll
costs Ruth's Chris the sorts it's to
keep their employees but it's trickle
down thousands of them probably give
that mind to the employees I think
that's what they're doing well that's
the idea behind the system right is like
well we'll be the companies and they pay
the employees I'm like no just directly
pay the [ __ ] people oh that's what
they can say but once they get the money
they might move it to somewhere and they
do they do stock buybacks to do all
kinds of [ __ ] well I know now in this
one I guess the in the in the previous
stimulus that's what they did in this
one they're like hey no stock buybacks
this time guys but they did all kinds of
other shifts what does that mean so you
get stimulus money and now you can give
it to your own board by buying your own
with the stimulus money you're not
filtering it down to the employees
because a lot of the ways businesses
manipulate credit and access is like
there's a gray area well this is
technically illegal but they do it
anyway so for example let's say I have
access my business has access to a
million dollars in credit what that
means is like hey man the bank looks at
my financials and they're willing to
loan me a million dollars to improve my
business but what a lot of business
owners or groups do is that they'll get
the million and instead of spending it
on their business they'll go ahead and
do real estate with it they'll do other
things they might buy another business
because once that money goes into your
account it's supposed to be used for
your business that's what that's why the
bank is loaning you the money because
they're looking at it as hey you're
gonna use it on expanding your business
you're gonna get more employees you're
gonna buy equipment whatever but a lot
of businesses don't do that they do
maneuver and kind of like use the way
use the access to that money to just go
ahead and make more money in a different
way what's amazing is that it's what do
they do right they get called out media
goes oh you guys should return the money
there's no investigation about how the
[ __ ] they were able to cut the line what
what Bank called them or they were able
to call who and who set it up and was
like yeah it was Chris no problem you're
fine but these small business people
here are completely [ __ ] and the money
sorry the bank accounts around we ran
out of money huh so that's what's crazy
is that there's never a clamor for
investigating they're actually putting
anyone in jail who's the gatekeeper
who's signing the checks
who's determining who gets what and why
nobody went to jail in 2008 ever for
anything that happened with the bailout
thought there were people who went to
jail at the end of what the Moneyball
was that won the big short yeah and then
at the credits they went this person
went to jail this pursuant to jail right
I don't think anyone from anyone from
any any high echelon if those companies
went to jail I don't think so I know I
know that I'm sure that they threw some
guys in the media to are at the media
and said yeah these guys are as a middle
tier guy they just take the blame
verne a key I think it was him they put
pressure on him but he didn't get in
trouble and he was the head of the Fed
at the time the Federal Reserve Freddie
Mae Fannie Mac CEO did they go to jail
like did did any of those guys go to
jail all the companies that benefit it
they didn't go to jail damn yeah there's
also um Shake Shack is in this
conversation because they could survive
I like their hamburgers I love their
hammers too but they announced that they
they announced their intentions to
return a ten million dollar SBA loan why
after acquiring additional capital
elsewhere they were like we didn't know
how this money would be distributed
distributed distributed when we applied
for the loan so it's just like a lot of
people were like we don't know what this
is it sounds like free money let's just
go and get it and then all these big
guys ended up getting a good chunk of
the money instead of where it should've
got a coincidence I mean I feel like any
company that has an accountant which is
every company it's like oh look the
government is giving away money we're
all gonna apply for it no matter what I
mean we signed up for it but our banker
told us that there's a huge list and
there's a huge chance we might not get
it so now it's recommended that you go
to more private lending companies or
smaller banks because there's a higher
chance of getting that if anyone out
there has a small businesses and you're
trying to get that PPP yeah it's crazy
because like we did it for Jay Kay did
it fly all the barbel stuff and then I
saw the qualifying loan amount and then
it was like eight thousand and I'm like
okay cool so like two employees get
covered for one month are you [ __ ]
kidding me $1,000 back kind of mouth and
I'm like we get more on a personal loan
than they are like so how is this
supposed to help us you should have done
a hedge funded are you [ __ ] kidding
it's like the hedge funds those guys
those guys get covered first in any
[ __ ] crisis yeah what is a hedge fund
I don't even know speculate on on stocks
and things on hedges right yeah it's a
it's legalized gambling basically you're
just betting against if things are gonna
go yeah oh I think that oil is gonna go
down you would've made a [ __ ] time
like it's it's actually what the part of
what the big short was about like well
we talked about this we talk about oil
but there's a there's something called
futures right so like you're basically
promising that for example like let's
say oil right like it takes time to
manufacture and all that stuff and I'll
be like TIFF I'm gonna buy your oil in
November at this price because I'm
generally thinking that by November you
know I can buy it for 20 bucks a barrel
right and then so that's kind of like a
promise contract or and then you can bet
against the future like you can bet
against like if that's really gonna
happen or not right and in so speculate
yeah there's even shorting which I'm
like I'm gonna bet it's not the way Joe
was gonna say yeah so it's just it's
literally like gambling it's like he's
betting that your company is gonna grow
and for some reason I'm betting that
York I don't believe enjoy your company
well you're betting on our contract yeah
so our contract is is basically I'm the
buyer like I'm Joe's gas and then your
Tiff's oil producer and then I'm I have
a contract with you by October right but
then the Rona happens and then I'm like
well [ __ ] I don't want to pay this price
anymore
and other people are gonna beat the
price and so that's when all the guys
that are speculating on what we're doing
win or lose and then what stuffs of the
people that are shorting it they're like
yes they failed because now I win it's
you're a congressman and you your stocks
got sold before the the Rona happened
which happened right people are like oh
no this sucks will get investigate this
[ __ ] and it's three people so far I
think three people total are getting
investigate laughs I wonder how many
more like when you think about how they
get elected and then they leave with
like a hundred million dollars of wealth
and then we're talking about these kinds
of marketplaces and these kinds of this
kinds of speculation if you were to know
the moves and things that were gonna
happen and all if you had somebody in in
power who was able to legislate that
didn't tilt things those directions you
could make a [ __ ] ton of money
I wonder how all these Congress people
get rich is [ __ ] while they're in office
like well everyone gets paid no one
wants to be accountable or find the
person that's accountable for it because
everyone
all the way and down the chain yeah I
don't think it would be so bad if they
like did that but they also were like
hey guys this is coming but coming from
the same representatives who are like oh
it's no big deal this is not gonna
affect you in any way at all and then on
the back of their best yeah and then
they're making all this money in the
back shady amazing shady sanctioned
completely legal no different than money
laundering but it's legal
[Music]
[Music]